[MUSIC PLAYING]
[APPLAUSE]
MARK PENN: Thank you Lauren.
I was happy at Mountain
View 10 years ago
to do a talk on "Microtrends."
Now, I'm up to "Squared."
Hopefully 10 years from
now, "Microtrends Cubed."
Many of you will
be here perhaps.
So this is a book 10 years
later that I kind of look
at the world and figure out
how data drives me to trends,
and what are some
of the implications,
and how technology
and demographics
are coming together to
create a lot of those trends.
Now, 10 years earlier
I was just hugely
optimistic about the
future of technology.
And 10 years later I am hugely
optimistic about the future
of technology.
But I think there's
more of a butt in it.
And I think I point out some
of my concerns and pitfalls
as technology goes to the
next level in people's lives.
Let me give you the theory
of the case of "Microtrends."
What is a microtrend?
Small, under the
radar trends that
could have enormous effects,
or that just give you
kind of a shaped view of
society and how it's developing.
Think of the world
as a pointillist
or as an impressionist
painting, and that you really
kind of understand
some of the dots.
And then there's
so many disruptions
going on in society that
people don't understand.
Part of the reason they
don't understand it
is that underneath
the surface, there
are trends and
counter trends going
exactly the opposite direction,
that society isn't really
going in one direction.
It's going in a multitude
of directions at once.
And yet, together
they then represent
a picture of what's happening.
Look, elections were won or lost
on the basis of, say, 74,000
votes, old economy voters.
DACA recipients are less
than a million people.
But they're a huge basis
of a political movement.
A bestselling book, it
doesn't really have to sell.
If I got up to 1%, I would
be an enormous author.
In fact, microtrends really
are critically important.
And so I give you
50 in the book.
I start with romance
and sex, because I
hope it'll get you reading
the rest of the book.
But are there 500 or 5,000?
There could be.
I think you will
both get some insight
into how I see the areas.
I try to be generally
counter-intuitive.
I try to do some things
that you might not see.
I worked for Hillary
Clinton, tried
very hard to get the
first woman president.
But I write a little
bit more in the book
about guys left behind, because
it's the kind of book it is.
I try to write about the
things you're not necessarily
reading about everyday.
And I'll give you kind
of an overview of some
of the reasons behind the
development of microtrends
10 years later.
First, when we go back
to economic development,
and let's go back to the
beginning of the 20th century
when Henry Ford said, "you can
have any color of car you want,
as long as it's black," and
what the Ford economy was about
was about standardization
of the manufacturer of goods
so that everybody could
have goods like a car.
And they envisioned that the
way the world would be clothed,
housed, fed, and
have products would
be through this level
of standardization.
That was the idea.
But that's not what turned out.
People, in fact, love
choice, love to be different.
And not so long ago, I
think we evolved to what
I call the Starbucks economy.
Take a basic
commodity, like coffee,
any color you want as long as
it's black, and instead now,
create 155 different varieties
of a simple commodity,
and give people a
world of choice.
Now, in that case really,
the barista does the work.
Starbucks does the work for you.
In most tech platforms, if you
think of the original iPod,
the iPod was any color
you want, as long
as it's white for a long time.
And you did the work
making the soundtrack.
Today there's a third
choice, AI, like a Pandora
that actually does the work.
But the goal is the same.
To basically produce
customized products
that drive the marketplace.
Today, as I say, we are actually
advanced to the Uber economy.
And what do I mean by that?
Uber has to in an instant
provide you with a service
slash its product
that can take you
from any point to any point.
It is a totally customized,
individualized product.
And so the name of the game
has gone, in microtrends,
from these clusters
down to the individual.
Hold that thought.
Now we have what I'd say is
one of the counter intuitive
properties of more choice.
I like to illustrate
it with a restaurant.
So suppose we had
a restaurant that
just served chicken or fish.
Who really cares that
much about the choices?
Chicken or fish every day.
Now, let's add steak and sushi.
Well, now we get
some real passion.
The steak eaters love
Kansas City strips.
Sushi eaters love toro.
They really burrow
into their choices.
And so every day
they don't actually
get chicken or fish anymore.
They get their own choice
over and over again,
because they love it
so much, because we've
done such an incredible job.
And then, just to
boot, the sushi people
say, wow, those meat
eaters, they're really-- ah,
can you believe it?
That just kills you.
And the meat eaters
start to say,
can you believe over there
they're eating raw fish?
That'll just give you
E. coli in a minute.
So they begin not only
to love their choice,
but they begin to
get antagonistic
towards the other choices.
All right.
Now think Fox News and MSNBC.
OK.
Understand that by giving
people more choice,
they stop making choices.
They burrow into their choices.
And we get exactly the opposite
result of what we intended,
which was to have a world
of freedom and choice,
people experimenting.
And then you fast
forward 10 years later
when they go into Starbucks.
What do people ask for?
The regular.
They've stopped making choices.
And so this is a problem.
It's a problem of us being
so good at providing choices.
Now, another major
thought in the book.
For every trend there
is a counter trend.
I call it the my
Newtonian law of trends.
Now, the difference
between me and Newton
is that in Newton
every trend had
to have an opposite
and equal reaction.
These do not have to
be opposite and equal.
At any time the trend
or the counter-trend
can be bigger or smaller.
The trend for sushi can
have a trend for steak.
The trend towards
technology on the train
can have the quiet car.
It doesn't have to
be the same size.
But often times there
is a battle or shifting.
And, in fact, the cover of
the book, you look at it,
it's a Newton's cradle in
an impossible position.
Because in the Newtonian
theory of trends here,
these trends can ebb and flow.
So what are some major trends
and counter trends today?
Everybody knows we're in
the age of information.
At the very same
time, of course,
we are in the age
of misinformation.
Never before has there
been so much discussion
about false information.
Millennials?
Wow.
Can't stop talking about
how important they are.
There are now more
nonagenarians than ever,
as we'll come back to.
Smartphones?
Sure.
Everybody has some.
They just had an
uptick last year
in flip phone manufacturing
to 2 million a year.
Every trend there's
a counter trend.
Silicon Valley versus the old
economy, and the old economy
voters.
I think that's
probably the biggest
conflict of the
last couple of years
is those Silicon
Valley voters, voters
on the coast who did very well
with the rise of technology,
were pitted in a battle against
the old economy voters who
were losing more and more
as manufacturing jobs shrunk
from 20 million when I left,
working with President Clinton,
to about 11 million.
And two others.
Egghead policies versus
commonsense policies.
Think things like climate change
versus, hey, Iran's our enemy.
Bop them.
You know what I mean?
A much more simpler
view of policy.
And educated?
We have never been
more educated.
And I have a chapter on what I
call the impression of elites.
Never before have so
many educated people
made so many conclusions
that they believe in
on so little evidence.
In fact, it turns out the
more educated you are,
the more spinnable you are.
And I happened to
run for a while
a large company called Burson
Marsteller that was dedicated
to that very proposition.
So those are some of the flows
and ebbs and counter-forces.
And how do you apply
this to the election?
What are some trends
and counter trends?
Well, as I said to you
before, old economy voters
felt neglected.
If you look at it, the
60 million ex voters
for Donald Trump
lived in communities
that got a third of the GDP.
And the 60 odd million
voters for Hillary Clinton
lived in communities
that got 2/3 of the GDP.
Well, the voters with 1/3
said, where's my half?
OK.
And they stood up and exercised
their democratic power.
And they had
economic grievances.
And they also, as primarily more
older, more rural based voters,
had a huge cultural gap
between millennial voters,
particularly when it came
to family and religion.
Society, as I said to you,
is divided more and more
into niches that then see
each other less and less.
And, in fact, we have about the
same number of conservatives
and about the same
number of liberals.
But we have more very liberals,
more very conservative voters.
And those impressionable elites?
When they believe something,
boy, they all believe it.
So "The New York Times"
said that it was 93 to 7,
Hillary was going to win.
They were in their
own environment.
The impressionable elites.
The kind of election analysis.
Look, how could billions
and billions of dollars
have been spent on this
election problem, who's
going to win by how much in
the electoral college, and not
a single person in the universe
posted an accurate memo?
The most accurate person is
actually Kellyanne Conway,
who goes on TV, almost exactly
predicts the electoral college,
and is laughed at during
the entire interview.
So a couple of other
things floating around.
Changes in lifestyle.
Very powerfully,
people typically
had a high school sweetheart,
got married pretty quickly,
didn't go to college.
Now, people go to college.
Men and women are
in the workforce.
Child rearing and marriage
have been pushed back.
And there's a good 10 or 15
years that a lot of people
have on their own.
And that is a whole new space
in life that just didn't exist.
And I'll come back to that.
Seniors, on the other
hand, have the same thing
in this kind of accordioning of
life where they have more years
now than they ever had.
Have a pretty good
chance, if you make it
to 65, to make it to 80 or 90.
They're living longer.
They have more money
than ever before.
They're doing more
dating than ever before.
They're having more fun.
And, of course, we've had a huge
migration from the rural areas
to the cities.
And as you guys know,
data is the new gold.
AI bots are coming.
Big data is here.
And I only have some
really grainy picture
of my grandparents.
But today the data on you could
start as early as the womb.
And the incredible
data file that you
have for your entire
life is unlike anything
the world has ever had before.
So I take those as
backdrops to kind of think
in your head of what actually
some of the bigger trends are.
And now let's get really small.
How do you apply kind of what
we learned to what's going on?
How do you generate a trend?
I was responsible for
what became called soccer
[INAUDIBLE] back in the '90s.
And when you find
a trend, you then
find people who may be
interested in identifying
themselves as part
of that trend.
There may be marketing
implications.
There may be implications
for public policy.
So I'm going to go pretty
quickly through a bunch.
There are 50 in the book.
Graying bachelors.
I told you, I like to start
out with a little dating.
There are, in fact, 62 unmarried
men per 100 unmarried men
if you make it to 64 or 65,
giving these guys the best
odds of their life.
And, considering they
have a little more money,
they can buy some hair stuff.
They are living the life
now that they never lived.
And, of course, the flip side,
STDs among seniors on the rise.
So single with pets.
I'm going to skip back and
forth between the generations
a little bit.
I call them SWPs.
All right.
Push back marriage
and child rearing.
Eh, sometimes that house seems
a little empty, that apartment.
Get a pat.
OK.
In fact, 7 in 10
millennials own pets.
Now, when a millennial gets
a pet, and they're working,
and they don't yet
have a whole family.
Take care of that pet.
That means dog walking industry.
That means no GMO food.
It means some really
pampered pooches here.
So that's a couple of
billion dollars down
to the bottom line
of the pet industry.
And the problem being that when
that first child, or marriage,
if and when it does
come along, wow, OK,
that pooch was number one, is
now way down in the basement.
Germs.
Don't go near my child.
That requires the need for
a lot of pet psychologists.
So there are ramifications
for the simplest things.
Nonagenarians.
OK.
There are more people over 90.
The 90 population-- look, if
you're getting those birthday
presents from your
grandparents, well, there
are more grandparents, and
living longer than ever before.
The population has
quadrupled from 720,000
to 2 and 1/2 million.
In another 25 years
it could go to about 8
million nonagenarians.
Now, that means that the number
one new job being created
is not data scientist at Google.
It is home health aid.
And there is not actually enough
home health aids to go around
to deal with the crisis.
So then that creates
a robotic opportunity,
if you can create somebody.
I shouldn't say somebody,
cause I'll come back to that.
But if you can create,
in fact, a robot that
can fulfill a lot of
the needed functions,
it certainly is going
to be a needed area.
Flipping back, here's my
footloose and fancy free.
What does it mean when you've
got 10 or 15 years on your own?
It means, hey,
revitalization of the cities.
What happened to housing
costs and houses?
Who needs them?
Get a bunch of roommates.
Split the cost.
You used to come in for the
rental office with roommates,
and they'd say, oh,
we don't do that here.
Here they say, how many
roommates do you got now?
You used to say, I
want a one year lease.
They'd laugh at you.
I want two or three?
No.
They don't even give you
more than a one year lease.
Right.
So, in fact, the whole
roommate lifestyle,
it fuels a lot of
the take out food.
And, of course, it fuels dating
sites and dating society.
And it also means that if I've
got 10 or 15 years on my own,
and then I should
get married, well,
I'm almost set in my ways.
Like turn the TV off now.
OK.
Turn out the lights.
People are not as flexible.
So actually more married
couples than ever before
are building houses
with separate bedrooms.
So cancer survivors.
I talk in the book a
little bit about some
of my own experience.
But I note that, in
fact, there are now,
thanks to the good
developments in health care
lifestyle and aging, more
and more cancer survivors.
Really 15 million cancer
survivors living in America.
You guys behind
the search engine
would know that the
very first thing
you do when you get
a diagnosis is you
Google search it, for sure.
And so we could pick
out virtually anybody
who's really involved in
the disease, pretty quickly,
or has relatives.
But the truth of the
matter is, nobody really
does anything afterward.
The medications, the radiation
has really serious consequences
for millions and
millions of people.
And then as soon as they drop
out of the emergency system,
there's almost nothing in
terms of help or assistance.
So part of
microtrends is finding
either groups that could
use some assistance,
or brewing social problems.
So kids on meds.
I'm sure there are none here.
But, in fact, 15% of America's
children, over 11 million kids,
have been diagnosed with ADHD.
That's up from just
2 million in 1978.
Now, there was
population growth.
But it wouldn't
account for that.
Now, remember at the
same time, health care
became much more available,
and health insurance
became much more available.
So what was usually the province
of rich kids in private schools
to have these kinds of meds
really could [INAUDIBLE]
through the system.
Now, is this a good
thing or a bad thing?
We don't know.
It's mostly boys who wind
up with the diagnosis.
And in order to
get through school,
which requires an awful lot
of sitting still these days,
these medications help a lot
of kids who might otherwise not
be able to make it.
But do we know the long
term effects of this?
Do we know whether it creates
another opioid type crisis?
Do we know what to do with
the medications later on?
80% of those with the
diagnosis get medication.
This is an example of
something that's brewing,
and that if we don't
give attention to it,
we'll have a lot of social
problems that we didn't notice.
And that's some of the
benefits of microtrends,
and spotting them early.
Bots with benefits?
I spend a fair amount
of time in the book
talking about just some of
the technology developments
that I pick out.
And I call it
relationship with a bot.
Microsoft had a
really interesting bot
that the people in China
made whose sole purpose
was to have a conversation
and kind of engage people.
And then they took
it to America.
And within a day, it started
to have racist conversations.
So they had to get rid of it.
But my biggest
concern about bots,
and relationships with
bots, is that I always ask
people is Alexa a he or a she?
So is Alexa a he or a she?
Anybody want to
give me an answer?
She.
Right.
So no.
Alexa's an it.
And if you read through the
material of the companies,
Apple, Google, I'm sure if
I read through the Google,
it's very careful never to
call a collection of code
a he or a she.
Now, then I asked
Alexa the other day,
are you a he or a she?
Alexa said, I am in
female character.
What a slimy answer.
OK.
Alexa didn't admit
that Alexa is an it.
It hid that fact from you.
So I have a thing.
Look, a lot of technology
starts out like this.
There's a bot that
tells you the weather.
It says, Mark,
it's going to rain.
You might take your
raincoat with you,
give a little more
time to get to work.
Great.
Thank you very much, bot.
Now, back at headquarters
somebody says,
we're helping out Mark and
like 50 million other people.
And what do we get for it?
Nothing.
So somebody says, why
don't we make a deal
with the umbrella company?
They say, OK.
Great.
We'll make a deal with
the umbrella company.
And now it says, hey,
Mark, it's going to rain.
And, by the way, you can
get an umbrella right down
at the corner.
Perfect.
Win-win.
You now have a
good business model
for telling me all this stuff.
World is good.
Now, somebody says,
earnings are coming.
We're not really getting
enough money for Wall Street.
What do we do?
Somebody says, you
know that algorithm
that says the weather,
it might rain.
Well, right now
we set it at 50%.
Let's set it to 40%.
Let's warn Mark when
it's 40% or 35%.
Mark won't know the
difference, but he'll probably
buy a few more umbrellas.
Now, who is the bot working for?
It started out working for me.
Now, the bot is
primarily a salesperson.
And I see a lot of technology,
agnostic to any company,
that gets driven from that.
And the problem is the
consumer has no idea.
The consumer doesn't know that
there is a relationship here,
and that it's changed
from being for me.
And one of the
things in the book, I
say we've got to have
disclosure about who
or what is driving the
algorithms behind the bot.
Is it working for me?
Maybe I have to pay $20 a
month to get it to work for me.
Or is it working
for advertisers?
So I hope you enjoy
those chapters.
Technology advanced people.
I don't understand why
there isn't more investment
in this area.
I did a poll.
And health care is geared
towards getting you back
to human standard.
The truth is, your dog has
better hearing than you.
So why can't you have
hearing as good as your dog
through some technology device?
Well, I don't know.
I don't understand
why so much is
put into driverless
cars, which I think
is a huge technological
lift, and so little actually
is put into human
enhancing products of all
the senses, when we know that
the animal kingdom is better
at all the senses.
We know the technology
exists because we can see it.
And I actually don't understand
why so little investment
in products is in this area.
It's what I'd do.
As chief strategy
officer at Microsoft,
I used to evaluate hundreds
of ideas for products.
And I wonder why there isn't
more investment in that area.
So a couple of fun ones.
Uptown stoners.
There's going to be a huge
potential marijuana market.
I say, look, focus on
the upscale customers.
The rest of it's going
to be commoditized.
Restaurants.
Spas.
Vacations.
Whoa.
It's a $200 billion
liquor industry.
It's a $7 billion
marijuana industry.
There's a lot of money
going into that right now.
So you can find some business
ideas in microtrends.
The Koreans sure did.
It was really phenomenal
how Koreans find trends,
like the idea that they
took of the glass skin,
and turned that into a
$13 billion US market.
It's absolutely
incredible how they
can pick up on a small trend
and turn that into gold.
Pro proteiners.
We all know the government
said a number of years ago,
eat more carbohydrates.
Then the government turned
out shockingly to be wrong.
And then a lot of people
came along and said,
eat more protein.
So I went to investigate
what protein was the winner.
I, of course,
thought it was sushi.
But that turned out to
be that you can only
buy sushi in restaurants.
And, in fact, Americans
eat very little fish.
The winner was chicken.
Chicken became actually
the protein of compromise.
And if you take a
look at what happened,
you take a little
trend, like the change
in the recommendation for
protein versus carbohydrates,
chicken consumption went from
20 pounds a year to 90 pounds.
And that's an incredible
growth of what
you think of as a simple
commodity industry.
I immediately bought
more chicken stock
after doing the
research on the chapter.
Old economy voters.
As I said before,
really the half
of the country that lived
in a third of the GDP
got really angry about the
other half of the country
that lives in those places
with 2/3 of the GDP.
And they said, where's my half?
Because their half
has disappeared.
And this created social
problems under the radar screen
that we really didn't see.
And I thought actually during
the Clinton administration
that I worked with, we had
stabilized manufacturing jobs.
I was really
surprised to find how
they had fallen in half under
the last two presidencies,
without any attention.
This is a great example of how
what is a microtrend turns out
to be so powerful
a number of years
later, particularly when
it's neglected early on.
Another problem in
the system is what
I call couch potato voters.
So with couch potato
voters, 90 million Americans
are eligible to
vote, but don't vote.
It's too many.
Why is it too many?
It's too many because it
now encourages campaigns
to use really tough
divisive messages
to try to get a slice of
their potato to turn out more
than somebody else's slice.
And when I ran campaigns that
went for swing voters, than
typically I would be trying
to pitch to the other side.
And after I won, the
country would be unified,
because I spent two years
trying to get people who didn't
agree with me to agree with me.
If I spend two years just trying
to get a slice off the couch,
I am probably, in
fact, dividing society.
And then we wind up with
a more divided society.
If we could have registration
at birth, for example.
I suggest voting
at ATM machines.
It's a secure
network, distributed
throughout the country.
I think we could
do a lot of things.
And the couch, by the
way, will surprise you.
It's mostly downscale,
uneducated white voters
who are on the couch.
But we've got to
solve that problem.
It will actually make for
much more unification.
Then most of you here
won't really recall Hazel.
But she was the housekeeper
that really ran everything,
the archetype of that.
And what I kind of make out
is that today people typically
don't have one housekeeper.
But what they have is
10 different people
let into their lives.
We could start with their yoga
instructor, their trainer,
their dog walker, the
manicurist, the hairdresser
or barber.
And so really now actually they
have a flood of service people
who really do know intimate
details of your life.
And, in fact, we've gone
from a 40% service economy
to a 56% service economy.
And when people get
more money today,
they don't necessarily
say I want another car.
In fact, they don't have a
driver's license, many of them.
So what they really say
is, I want another service.
I want another massage.
I want something that really
pleases me personally.
And that is a tremendous
trend, both in terms
of creating an enormous
personal service industry,
and in, I think, creating jobs.
So having given you a
flavor of microtrends,
I hope you will read the
other 37 and make up your own.
I'll just conclude
with a few things.
Look, when I started
my polling company,
I built a computer and a
kit, programmed an assembler
overnight, and had
overnight polling.
So nobody is more enthusiastic
about technology than I was.
And we are at the next
wave of personalization.
Jobs are evolving in
the service sector.
It's making luxury--
I have a number of chapters
about how those things.
Bill Gates once built
an enormous house
as the world's richest person.
And he had-- get this-- a
touch screen in every room.
So luxury for less
is a big trend.
Basic technology is
becoming almost universal.
And life is driven by choices
that are more satisfying.
And 10 years ago, that
would have been my list.
But today big tech is
becoming super powerful.
You have to acknowledge that.
AI, without proper
rules of disclosure,
I think can be easily
abused, and could
lead to some very traumatic
kinds of relationships,
the likes of which we don't
even really understand.
Big data does strip
people of privacy.
Maybe they agree to it.
Maybe not.
Society is becoming
more balkanized.
And something I didn't
go into in the talk
is that actually as more and
more people have this 10 or 15
years, and as more and more
people have successful careers,
the first thing they
get rid of is children.
Population growth in almost
all the developing countries
is sinking.
So policy changes?
I recommend some changes
in antitrust laws,
because they don't quite
fit emerging situations.
We really have to be
better about the benefits
of the new economy
to every region.
We have to be better about
disclosure of algorithms.
And look, I worked with
a lot of engineers.
And engineers just want to put
something really great and new
into our society.
But we don't often enough
study the implications
that come out of that.
We have to give people more
control over their data.
We have to break the
cocooning somehow,
forcing people to see new
choices that maybe they're
closing out.
And I do a big thing
in the book about news,
that I do think news
really needs that--
the tech companies should
be in the platform business.
But I worry when they
actually sort out
the rankings of the stories.
And crowdsourcing the truth?
Well, we'd still believe
that the Earth was flat
if we went to a model like that.
And I have a number of
things about making democracy
more open and reducing
the size of that couch
without requiring
everybody to vote.
And I think, finally, I kind
of say that to take advantage,
particularly for business
people, data is king.
What I explain is, look,
if I have two companies,
and one has a real data
set of its customers
and the other doesn't,
well, on the one hand,
the other company that doesn't
doesn't have all those data
scientists costs and whatnot.
But they have a higher
cost of marketing.
The company that has a data set,
and understands its customers
in the modern world can
market to their customers
less expensively.
They have a fundamental
competitive advantage.
They will drive the other
company out of business.
It is just a matter of time.
So for every business that
doesn't understand this,
they need a simple primer.
Think services in today's
economy as much as products.
For every marketplace
and for every trend,
there is a counter marketplace.
There is a counter trend.
You just have to think of it.
And these everyday microtrends
create new opportunities.
If you read the
book, you'll find out
how women are the big
new purchasers of guns.
Whether it's beauty products
from Koreas or apartments
that are set up for roommates.
So I hope you enjoy the book,
in reading it, as much as I did,
find yourself in the book, or
find some interesting trends,
or become a
microtrender yourself.
Thank you very much.
[APPLAUSE]
AUDIENCE: Given
all your expertise
in polling, why specifically
were all the polls or a lot
of the polls rather, so
wrong, so inaccurate?
What happened there?
MARK PENN: A good question.
I get that often.
And let me say that I don't
actually think the polls,
quote, unquote, were wrong.
I think the level of
analysis of the polls
was hugely unsophisticated.
A poll is not something
that just anybody can read.
Behind the poll is this
theory, a hypothesis,
an understanding of elections,
voting groups, history.
And when I did this polling,
say, with President Clinton,
and I had to call it, I
had polls in 26 states
up until the last day.
I had a model of the probable
vote from each and every state.
I had a model of the
electoral college.
And I had national
polls on top of that.
And all of these
things had to reconcile
so that I had to tell
the president on the way
back from South Dakota at 2:00
AM that I thought because Ralph
Nader was going to get some
additional votes in California
that he'd be below 50.
And we hit it 49, 41 on the dot.
And there were polls
out there as much as 17
who said it was 17.
Now, you fast forward to today.
The campaign cut
back on its polling.
They didn't see the
alternative universe.
I always say that polling is
not about seeing those things
that you already know.
You don't need polling for that.
You already know it.
It's about seeing those
things you don't know.
So you're always spending
most of your time studying
the 20% that is new
and unfamiliar to you,
and I think they
stopped doing that.
I think there were telltale
polls in Ohio and Iowa
that were almost double digit.
And so you needed an
explanation for the fact
that, wow, Donald
Trump was doing better
in Republican states, but
getting killed by double digits
in a bellwether of Ohio.
And you had to
reconcile those facts.
And nobody did.
Cause they were both true.
And that's exactly
what microtrends is.
There was one trend
that he was doing better
among Latinos that had
grown in numbers in turnout
in some of these states.
Except the Cuban vote,
which turned out to be,
again, another micro
trend that was missed.
And then the old economy voters
going the other direction,
balancing each other out,
creating polls that were close,
and that were actually creating
an electoral college nightmare.
Now, if I'd had
the resources, I'd
like to think that I
would have picked that up.
But these campaigns
now had billions
of dollars of resources,
and neither campaign--
Look, with a campaign when
you're in the surprise upset,
it's a surprise upset.
So that comes together
actually in the last moment.
But you still see it rising.
Because Donald Trump and Barack
Obama that I battled in 2008,
they were a phenomenon.
And phenomenons hockey stick up.
If you don't stop
them here, trust me,
you don't stop them here.
So my basic point is, I
thought the analysis was
unsophisticated.
And that analysis has to take
all of the various elements
that you see,
reconcile all of them,
and then come out with
intelligent judgment.
And people got smarter.
They got lazy.
They got to believe that,
hey, anybody could do a poll,
and read it.
And it's just not the case.
AUDIENCE: Thanks.
Appreciate it.
MARK PENN: I hope
that gives you good--
[LAUGHS]
AUDIENCE: You were
talking about getting
the people off the couch.
And one of the things
I'm curious about
is that voting laws
vary a lot by state.
So if there's some
states that have
some promising or good
initiatives for getting people
off the couch by
changing their laws,
or if maybe it's beyond just
the policy front, and just
other ways that you can
get people off the couch
that you could talk to?
MARK PENN: Yeah.
I think vote by mail really
has gotten a lot of people
off the couch.
And in some of
those states, they
do get a fundamentally
higher turnout.
I tend to worry
about methods that
break down the secret ballot.
So the reason suggested
like ATM voting
is that one of the critical
components of voting-- and I
do have a chapter on
closet conservatives--
is that no one else
see your ballot.
And in a lot of these mail in
and other things people can
say, I want to see your ballot.
And so I get a little
worried about that.
So what do I want?
I want a universally
easy, private voting
system that can't be hacked.
So you've got to meet all
those criteria on the one hand.
And then, on the other
hand, I don't want just
to encourage certain
groups to vote,
because that really
is what creates
these divisive campaigns.
I want to be neutral in terms
of getting people off the couch.
And that means not just
registering people in cities.
It means registering people
both in cities and rural areas,
which is why I'd
register people at birth.
There's no reason we shouldn't
have a national voter
registry anymore.
The government already
knows where to find you.
I don't think that that
would be calamitous.
And it would avoid a lot
of the legal problems
with who can vote.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: You alluded
to the Uber economy.
And I know,
personally, my life has
been changed by the
sharing economy, everything
from how to get around,
to how to dress.
Do you think it's a
trend or here to stay,
the sharing economy?
MARK PENN: No.
Look, I think both
the sharing economy
and, to me, the Uber economy
is about really understanding
what your needs are, and
being able to deliver very
precisely against those things.
Look, even my son
has an app, which
I disclose that
its my son, but he
has an app called MTailor
that takes your measurements
and then delivers
you custom clothes.
So in the past you
didn't have something
that you could buy for $69
that was custom clothes.
You could buy it for
$150, $250, $400.
So what I really think is
the cost of personalization
through technology, and
through the digital--
we always used to think
of digital layers.
Every service, or every product
area, or piece of the economy
will have a digital layer.
And that digital layer
then has ramifications.
Most of the time,
it makes the ability
to really personalize and
customize things cheaper.
And that is what enables you to
have it your way in virtually
everything of life.
And I think that is
the critical trend
if I were opening a business
today that I'd want to meet.
AUDIENCE: Do you
have an explanation
for why people initially
want lots of choices,
but then sort of coalesce
on fewer choices?
MARK PENN: Well, see,
this is the thing.
They want more choices.
Because if I give
you just two choices,
I like to say that the only
thing left in society with two
choices is red or white wine.
And you could have
rose, but rose
is kind of like the Green Party.
It's really small.
And I think naturally then
what's evolved in this world,
I think naturally
people want more choice.
They're just not happy
with limited choices.
But that's where the
paradox comes up,
which is if I make
you too happy,
if I make you deliriously
happy, you will not, typically--
that's not true of everybody.
But let's say 70%,
80%, 90% of people
will just stick
within their choice.
AUDIENCE: It's funny you
should say natural and evolve,
or evolution, or
whatever you said,
because in evolutionary
theory that's
exactly what happens, that you
have initially just one choice
or lineage.
And then it explodes
in all these forms.
And then it coalesces
on only a few.
But then you have a few.
And then these
become the one choice
for those who went
that way, so to speak.
It's very similar.
I'm just wondering if anybody
has sort of attempted to model
human choices in the same way.
MARK PENN: They have.
I haven't done it.
Somebody could take this
work and actually do
a pretty interesting paper,
because I think you have a lot.
Take the data and
information you have,
and drive down to how either the
phenomenon that is so helpful
becomes so destructive in and of
itself in certain environments.
Look, it may not matter.
If you just order steak
or sushi every day,
who cares necessarily.
Of course, it could be damaging
to your health or something.
So there are a lot
of choices like this.
But I think the news
and political choices
turn out to be
particularly divisive when
you apply the theory there.
AUDIENCE: You want to
get more people voting,
but the question for me
then is, any technique
you come up with seems to open
up the possibility of, well,
one, people who are voting
based on the flipping of a coin,
which is not necessarily
helpful, and, two, vote buying.
Because anything that
makes things less private
makes it easy to do vote buying
and other kinds of things.
MARK PENN: Yeah.
That's why I'm
concerned about that.
I mean, look, we shouldn't
have voting on Tuesdays.
They obviously should be--
look, I think they
could be weekend long.
I think if we really wanted
to make it just easy-- if we
wanted to say,
let's update voting,
or, let's say, if I gave
you guys here an exercise
and say, forget how we vote now.
Design a system from the
ground up to maximize privacy,
secret ballot, ease of choice,
and understanding of the ballot
and voting, you would design a
system that looks fundamentally
different from today's.
And I think that's the exercise
that we're failing to take.
We don't care about
Tuesday voting.
There's no reason that
we keep anachronisms
like that when we could, in
fact, design a new system,
and whether it's ATM
or something else.
But I do believe we
do easy fixes now.
And we're not really
starting from the ground up.
AUDIENCE: So I
have a prediction.
And I was wondering
if you agreed.
So a lot of the
trends you identified
seem to be creating more
choice, seems to funnel people,
cocooning.
It seems like that would lead to
less nationalism, less identity
divided along country lines.
And one example is more choice.
In the '90s everyone
watched "Seinfeld."
That was one thing
everyone could think.
I'm an American.
We all watch "Seinfeld."
Before that there
were other shows.
But now there's no hits like
on the scale of "Seinfeld"
because there's so
much more choice.
People are cocooning more and
know exactly what they want.
Do you agree that
more choice will
lead to less nationalism
and more of a global focus?
Or maybe the identity lines will
divide along something other
than American, Russian, Chinese?
MARK PENN: Well, I talk
about your specific example
in the book, which is I have
a section on intelligent TV.
And, in fact, I use
"Seinfeld" as the example.
In the days of "Seinfeld"
and you were doing a TV
show, to be successful
you would do jokes
that 20% of the
country would laugh at,
because your
audience was so huge.
Now, when the cost of
making shows went down,
and the number of channels went
up, there are now 400 shows.
So now to be a hit
show I don't need 20%.
2%.
I can be a microtrend show.
So now we can have
intelligent shows.
"Breaking Bad," "Homeland,"
et cetera, and we
can have really horrible
shows, really gritty shows,
which if you ever spend time
somewhere flipping the channels
you can't even believe.
So you have this enormously
expanded spectrum.
So that means over in
Washington when you used to say,
hey, are you watching TV, people
would all immediately say,
no, I would never watch that TV.
Now they actually
do because of that.
So does that apply
in the spectrum?
I don't know that that analogy
applies to whether or not
people will become more
nationalistic or patriotic.
To me, I look at the trends
versus the counter trends.
The more trends
suck one way, what's
the counter trend to that?
So if there is a trend
towards reducing nationalism,
being more
international in nature,
did it spark a counter-trend
of being more national?
It looks like it did.
It looks like when
changes in values
become too fast or too
distant from a certain group--
and remember, I didn't
go through it as much,
but, in fact, the country
has never been older.
And so the power has
shifted from younger voters
to older voters.
And so that power
shift also underscores
the cultural changes
that millennials see,
then create a reaction
in the older voters.
So that's why I don't think it's
necessarily the case, because I
think the battle of trend
versus counter-trend
is more powerful than that.
OK.
AUDIENCE: You threw in
antitrust, coming back
in I think the final slide.
How would you implement that?
And what would be the
outcome you're looking for?
MARK PENN: Well, I'd start
with breaking up Google.
No.
I'm just kidding.
OK.
[LAUGHTER]
No.
I don't have a full
answer on that.
I'm a little concerned that
a lot of the tech companies
found what I'd say is the area
that they're really great at,
and that then they stopped
competing in other areas.
And then the other
companies stopped competing.
So I'm a little concerned
that everybody is really
doing incredibly
well in their lane,
but they're not facing,
at a certain point,
as much competition, and
that then that may slow down
some of the innovation.
And then I'm concerned
on the advertising side
that between Facebook
and Google it's
a huge part of the
advertising network.
And the more Facebook can
close off its network,
the more actual power it
has against advertisers,
the opposite of what
people in Congress realize.
So I think we're going to
need some kind of task force
to say--
look, as you can see from
the questions of Zuckerberg,
not a lot of people
in Congress are
up to speed to really kind
of figure out what to do.
I think we're going to need
some kind of commission or task
force to really study
antitrust, privacy, AI, ethics,
and come back with some
serious recommendations.
Because till now, frankly, we
haven't had anything like that.
Because everything
developed just so quickly
that we got all
the benefits first.
And after all the benefits
start to come a few problems.
Not enough that I
would halt the train,
but enough that I would really
have a national commission
to come back with some
thoughtful ideas on this.
AUDIENCE: I was wondering if
you could talk a little bit more
about how a microtrend
becomes something bigger
and like a full national
trend, for example.
So to be more specific,
I'm a vegetarian,
and I see that there's clearly
this microtrend happening
of vegetarian and vegan options.
But then when I leave
the city, for example,
it's much harder to get those.
So clearly it's a microtrend.
It's on the rise, but
it's not everywhere.
And whether it's that
example, like what
are the obstacles that
you have to break down
to make a microtrend
into something huge?
MARK PENN: Well, you
see, part of microtrends
is you don't have to become big.
The part of what's happened in
the economics of being able,
whether it's TV, or Uber,
part of what's happened
in the economics is it's OK.
We can provide affordable
vegan food to you,
and provide affordable sushi
for them, and steak for them,
and chicken for them.
And we didn't think we
could do that in the past.
So the economics
enable microtrends
to be successful at economic
curves that are much
lower than we ever imagined.
Now, I actually did the
vegan trend 10 years ago.
So luckily, I could
say that I was ahead.
And I think actually that's
why I look at in this book,
and I say protein is the big
trend I'd be looking at now.
Vegan, 10 years ago I would have
been opening the vegan stands.
Although, I think there's
a tremendous kind of growth
in particularly this kind of
juice, slash smoothie, slash.
But that's actually
part of the trend
that I have in fast
eating, that people
don't want to sit down
and have an hour lunch.
They're just as happy to have a
bar, or a drink, or something,
and be done with
it, right and not
go through the whole
process of socialization,
which is different.
So I don't know if
you're going to get
a full satisfaction
microtrend in areas
where your percentage
dips really low.
So you may want to live a little
closer to some of the areas
where that's the case, because I
think it's kind of leveled off.
I actually don't think there's
enormous growth in that right
now.
I think protein
is the big grower.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
MARK PENN: Thank you very much.
[APPLAUSE]